day 15 8:42 p.m. man we got it ahead
actually a few interesting train
situations today I mean - whoa Muffy
yeah 734 this mores like a nasty high
school cheerleading squad you know how
like you're not included this guy must
be really cool mom JAMA make some
foreign woman okay here make this red
hood man is he really bothering this
child sitting behind him I didn't tell
you about um the apartment I went to see
in Astoria it was 10:30 and I was at
Penn Station
this lady answers what what's it what's
it bought the appointment at 11:00 put
that down Jordan like when people call
me a woman like what the hell Everybody
Loves Raymond 50 years later that sister
this lazy eye that just want yeah oh
you're right in front of me don't make
eye contact and smile at me it's just
weird
Oh apparently [ __ ] are not cheating
I didn't I didn't mean to do that I'll
stab you
I ran about two blocks I'm right you
know what sounds good walking became too
damn tired maybe he was sleeping with
his eyes open
I don't know how many guys are walking
around with warts kiss see Chinese yes I
don't wanna mention that and then I
realized that I'm not British Monday was
a really good day this is Facebook first
face to face face to face what's up I
just grab people by the top of their
head and gently place them to the side
they have those things they're called
prosthetic arms right on his ass trying
to pull out is bad look I want to be a
dirty bastard and I want her to be a
dirty naughty girl anything else
happened today under 15